bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 78
lactu nous allons faire le tour de
l'actualité local avec ce journal de la
rédaction voici les principaux titres
l'année 2014 qui débute par la mise en
place d'un nouveau plan de transport
dans l'aglomération yvelinoise à 50 ans
en Yveline les transports affichent un
nouveau visage présentation détaillée
avec notre invité de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin retour également sur notre
rétrospective de l'année 2013 focus sur
les événements marquants de l'été
dernier et puis gourmand et fabophil
heureux en ce 6 janvier jour de
l'épiphanie nous verrons comment se
prépare dans une boulangerie la
traditionnelle galette des rois l'image
du jour c'est le déplacement de
Jean-Marc hraud et d'une délégation du
gouvernement à Versailles cet après-midi
c'est Aure château de Versailles que le
ministre de l'Emploi ministre du droit
des femmes et ministre de la réforme de
l'État ainsi que le premier ministre ont
rencontré des représentants de la
société était l'aîné de l'eau en charge
de travaux de restauration du pavillon
du four un déplacement sur le thème de
la mixité professionnelle et le droit
des femmes puisque cette entreprise a
développé un programme d'amélioration et
d'aménagement des postes pour les rendre
accessibles et adapté à ces dernières le
Premier ministre a aussi présenté les
actions que le gouvernement engagera en
2014 objectif 1/ers des métiers mixtes
en France d'ici à 2025 une campagne de
communication et puis un plan d'action
mixité seront également lancer la visite
du gouvernement qui s'est terminé il y a
quelques instants si vous nous suivez en
direct à 18h le résumé complet sera donc
à découvrir dans notre édition de demain
mardi aujourd'hui 6 janvier
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline dévoile sa nouvelle offre de
transport objectif simplifier les
déplacements des résidents mais aussi
des salariés du territoire et je reçois
Muriel Laroui bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau responsable des transport en
commun pour la communauté
d'agglomération de de Saint-Quentin on
va parler de ces nouveautés mais déjà
tout d'abord quels sont les les modes de
trans trans qui sont concernés on parle
uniquement du du transport en bus
transport en bus et transport en car
transport en car également parmi cette
nouvelle offre que vous mettez en place
c'est régulier tous les ans il y a vous
met à J généralement on essaie de faire
ça au mois de septembre de manière à ce
que les voyageurs puissent s'organiser
au niveau vie familiale parfois les
plannings sont un petit peu plus
contraints et la nouvelle offre de la
ligne 475 n'aura été mise en place que
en janvier après des nouveautés de
septembre cette 475 c'est la nouveauté
ma grand né ça concerne quel trajet
c'est une liaison jusqu'à Paris port
d'orléand depuis saint-quenttin en
yeline mais pas seulement depuis la gare
de Saint-Quentin puisque la ligne part
de hencour clé de Saint-Pierre dessert
pissalou fait la gare de Saint-Quentin
mais également la commune de Guill
encour donc c'est une ligne très
fréquentée c'est une ligne qui existait
avant mais avec que quelques courses on
avait vraiment TR qu courses le matin
tro qu courses le soir elle n'existait
pas en heure creuse elle ne fonctionnait
pas le samedi la grande nouveauté c'est
qu'elle est maintenant labellisée ligne
express par par le Syndicat des
transports hî-de-fance et elle a donc
connu grâce au Syndicat des transports
hî-de-fance une amélioration vraiment
importante on a maintenant des courses
de 6h le matin jusqu'à 21h30 le soir du
lundi au vendredi mais également le
samedi ce qui permet aussi aux
cinquantinois de rejoindre Paris pour
des loisirs les sol pas uniquement pour
les salariés pour les gens qui vont all
voilà donc on a vraiment pour les deux
publics les salariés qui quittent
Saint-Quentin ou qui viennent sur
Saint-Quentin en semaine et les
Saint-Quentinois ou des amis de
sa-quentinois qui peuvent venir sur mais
c'était une demande de la population
comment fa en place dem alors'était une
demande récurrente puisqu'il y avait une
surcharge récurrente le matin à sur sur
le coup de HH entre entre Paris et et
Saint-Quentin euh cette ligne était
quand même inscrite au plan
d'Île-de-France au Plan de Déplacement
Urbain d'Île-de-France comme ligne
express et donc elle a connu un renfort
dans ce cadre-là pour me vraiment
répondre aux besoins des salariés mais
également sur les déplacements en heure
creuse puisque il y a une offre
maintenant euh à l'heure tout au long de
la journée en plus de la fréquence au
quart d'heure ou à la demi-heure en
heure de pointe 550 en Yveline 2ième
pôle économique en Île-de-France
derrière la défense là çaen est une
illustration justement c'est pour
renforcer cette position voilà et c'est
une liaison vraiment rapide et
confortable on passe par la 86 c'est de
l'autoroute les voyageurs sont installés
dans des cars très confortables les
conducteurs connaissent bien leur métier
ils connaissent déjà bien l'itinéraire
donc ce sont des voyages vraiment peu
fatiguants vous pouvez tout à fait
utiliser votre trajet pour consulter
votre téléphone portable il n'y a aucun
souci voilà ça sera pas comme dans le
métro il y aura un petit un peu moins de
fréquentation vous serez tranquille si
vous utilisez cette cette ligne de de
transport on va représenter les les
autres nouveautés qui vont être mises en
place juste pour le public qui nous
regarderait qui n'aurait pas encore
connaissance de tous ces nouveaux
horaires ces nouveaux modes de
fonctionnement où est-il possible de
s'informer alors le plus simple si vous
souhaitez des informations c'est le site
de cintquanttin en Yveline donc
www.sqy.fr à partir de là vous avez la
rubrique se déplacer vous avez LAN
ensemble des lignes de bus de
Saint-Quentin mais pas seulement celle
de skibus vous avez les 27 autres lignes
présentes sur le territoire des lignes
qui vont aussi bien jusqu'à Massie et
Orli que jusqu'à la défense jusqu'à
sergie mant la jolie nous avons vraiment
une offre très importante urbaine et
interurbaine et l'ensemble de l'offre
est connue sur le site de Saint-Quentin
et tous les secteurs sont couverts où il
y a encore des des endroits il faut
mettre l'accent sur
l'agglomération il y a un vrai travail
avec le Syndicat des transports
l'île-de-fance pour mailler notre
territoire au reste de l'Île-de-France
pour mieux développer des liaisons par
exemple vers sergie vers poissie vers
manth des liaisons qui peuvent déjà
exister mais qu'il faudrait renforcer
mais également créer des liaisons plus
importantes vers la défense par exemple
ou vers nantire donc du travail de de
réflexion et d'étude est en cours quels
sont les autres modification on va
revenir sur les nouveautés de de cette
année il y a un code couleur différent
déjà alors avant même de parler de la
représentation du réseau une autrere
nouveauté concerne principalement le
secteur du Technocentre il s'agit d'une
offre pour les salariés on a travaillé
sur une meilleure adéquation entre la
ligne 460 qui fait Agard sa-qu1 et le
Technocentre avec la ligne 416 4110 qui
elle va jusqu'à Massier et orlit les
salariés depuis septembre avaient une
meilleure offre sur la 416 4110 mais la
460 n'était pas bien calé sur ses
horaires et donc depuis depuis
aujourd'hui les salariés disposent une
offre toutes les 15 minutes du
Technocentre vers la gare de
Saint-Quentin pour pouvoir revenir
prendre leur train et là aussi c'était
une demande forte des salariés j'imagine
c'était une demande des salariés qui
trouvait qu'il y avait vraiment une des
trous puisque les les courses peuvent se
suivre à 5 minutes et après il y avait
un trou de 25 minutes donc là vraiment
on a on a un vrai quart
d'heure comme le matin en fait les
salariés qui veulent aller au
Technocentre ont une course toutes les
quart d'heures le matin et maintenant on
aussi une course tous les quart d'heures
le soir c'est important pour que ces
entreprises restent implantées he sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin on le sait
il faut qu'il y a du transport sinon
forcément ça complique un peu un peu les
choses c'est l'attractivité de
l'agglomération qui joue par les
transports en commun surtout sur ces
lignes interurbaines qui sont aussi un
des moyens pour les sal de ne pas perdre
de l'énergie dans des déplacements
quotidiens autres changement pour les
bus les car est-ce qu' alors les autres
changements c'est pas des changements
sur l'OF c'est des changements sur la
lisibilité du réseau le fameux code
couleur alors le fameux code couleur
donc on le syndicat des transport
ilî-defrance avait lancé une grosse
réflexion avec des consultants des
cartographes depuis 3 ou 4 ans et ils
ont défini une nouveau une nouvelle
manière de représenter les réseaux de
bus les réseaux de train on est le
premier réseau à avoir appliqué cette C
nouvelle charte euh alors c'est
peut-être pas complètement parfait mais
en tout cas on a appliqué le principe
qui est suivi par le STIF qui préconise
de regrouper les lignes par catégories
et les catégories sont définies par le
niveau de service donc on va avoir une
couleur orange une couleur chaude forte
pour dire que cette ligne là elle est
forte elle est solide vous pouvez y
aller sans guide d' horaire vous aurez
un bus toutes les 5 à 10 minutes en
heure de pointe au quart d'heure en
heure creuse vous avez une autre couleur
vous avez des lignes qui sont regroupées
dans un paquet vert ben ce paquet vert
sont les lignes complémentaires vous
avez une offre à 10 minutes en heure de
pointe à la demi-heure en heure creuse
et donc sans guide horaire vous savez
déjà quelle est l'offre disponible sur
le secteur où vous voulez vous rendre ou
du secteur d'où vous partez on sait si
on va devoir patienter ou non entre
entre deux passages le voilà savoir si
vous pouvez vous rendre sans aucun sans
sans préparation à l'arrêt de bus parce
que vous savez qu'il y a une très bonne
fréquence à cet arrêt de bus ou s'il
vous faut préparer le voyage en repérant
quel est l'horaire adéquate pour
descendre ou pour vous rendre à votre
arrêt c'était très important sur
Saint-Quentin puisqu'on est un
territoire avec une forte attractivité
aux heures de pointe pour des salariés
qui vont entrer sur notre territoire et
on avait 16 lignes qui ne fonctionnaient
que aux heures de pointe et ces lignes
étaient représenté au même titre que les
autres sur notre réseau qui pouvait
induire en erreur les voyageurs les
voyageurs disaient ah mais on a une
offre et il y avait toujours beaucoup de
déceptions derrière ben oui mais elle
fonctiontionne que aux HE de pointeors
beaucoup plus visible le but c'est
d'homogénéiser tout toute l'Île de
France va pass voilà toute l'îne de
France passera avec ce système de code
couleur si vous devez ensuite utiliser
les transports en commun à travers
l'île-de-fance ce sera beaucoup plus
plus clair juste pour pour pour conclure
on a parlé aussi de la hausse de la TVA
ces derniers jours au 1er janvier est-ce
que il y a une répercussion sur le le
réseau de de déplacement alors le
syndicat transport -defance et la région
Île-de-France ont fait un effort
important pour minimiser le coût de la
répercussion qui aurait dû être plus
important il y aura peut-être moins
d'investissement cette année pour
récompenser mais ou il y a une légère
hausse de la TVA au 1er janvier comme ça
qui sera forcément répercuté si vous
devez utiliser les transports en commun
mais ça sera les mêmes tarifs sur
l'ensemble de V defance euh pour mémoire
et pour Rael les passes Navigo sont
utilisables sur le réseau interurbain au
même titre que les tickets et plus
valable dans le réseau de métro donc si
vous avez besoin d'utiliser cette
nouvelle ligne 475 ou la ligne
Massi mass Orly que nous avions présenté
au mois de septembre vous pouvez vous
présenter avec vos ticket et plus et
vous pourrez voyagerà m Orly un seul
ticket merci beaucoup d'être venu Muriel
Laroui présenter donc ce nouveau plan de
de transport sur 50 ans en Eveline je
rappelle aussi que jusqu'au 23 janvier
vous pouvez découvrir le nouveau plan
local de déplacement et faire part de
vos observations ça concerne l'ensemble
des modes de transport sur SaintQuentin
en Yveline consultation possible à
l'hôtel d'agglomération à l'agence de la
mobilité à la Maison de l'environnement
ou encore dans l'une des SEP mairies de
la communauté d'agglomération pour
laisser toutes vos remarques jusqu'au 23
janvier le 6 janvier c'est aussi
l'occasion de fêter l'épiphanie et pas
uniquement pour la communauté chrétienne
qui célèbre la visite des Rois mages à
l'enfant Jésus mais aussi pour les
gourmands qui peuvent déguster les
alette les amateurs de fèv les
fabophiles sont aussi ravis reportage
dans une boulangerie c'est du sirop
c'est de l'eau et du sucre qu'on a fait
bouillir tout simplement voilà c'est ce
qu' les fait briller toujours chaud à la
sortie du four
elle célèbre la visite des Rois magages
auprès de l'enfant Jésus elle c'est bien
sûr la galette de l'épiphanie à
Chevreuse dans la boulangerie pâtisserie
d'Hervé Bové on la cuisine de manière
traditionnelle du beurre frais de la
poudre d'amande 100 % pur fruit du du
sucre de la farine et de la crème
pâtissière pour la fryane ici la méthode
est
artisanale tout est fait à la main alors
il y a qu'une seule machine même deux a
une machine qui aide à faire la crème
c'est le batteur mélangeur et une autre
machine qui s'appelle le laminoir pour
étaler la
pâte par que quand il y a beaucoup de
pâtes voilà ce sont les se machin tout
est fait à la main une méthode
traditionnelle qui élève forc le tarif à
la caisse alors qu'elle coûte de 4 à 10
€ en grande surface les galettes aussi
iront plus entre 10 et 20 € chez un
artisan patissier pourtant les clients
restent fidèles au rendez-vous ici c'est
la pâtisserie est très bonne c'est pour
ça j'aime mes artisans chez Madame bvet
tout est bon et qu' part c'est pas si
bon on en a pour son argent hein il y en
a qui sont pas
difficiles près de 20 millions de
galettes sont achetées chaque année en
France à Chevreuse de 750 à 1500 pièces
seront vendu en un mois et demi ce qui
représente environ 15 % du chiffre
d'affaires d'Hervé Bové presque autant
que pour les fêtes de
Noël et si la galette reste le gâteau le
plus prisé dans notre région début de
mois de janvier dans le sud la recette
est sensiblement différente une brioche
au sucré au fruits confit baptisé coque
ou couronne des rois alors galette ou
coque vos choix vos réponses avec ce
micro trottoir la galette des rois c'est
plus pour l'appétit le fait de manger
une pâtisserie plutôt Gal des rois
pourquoi c'est une tradition je pense
ben nous on a l'habitude de manger à
galett des rois mais pourquoi pas goûter
cette coque des RO la galette quand même
la galette de RO pourquoi parce que je
sais pas c'est bon je suis pas très très
fan mais mon mari et mes enfants ils
adorent ça ah non c'est galette des rois
alors pourquoi parce que les fruits sec
les fruits non j'aime pas trop mais
c'est plutôt galette pourquoi vous êtes
c'est plus par tradition je n'aime pas
la galette des RO d'accord pourquoi
parce que je n'aime pas c'est pas c'est
pas un gâteau qui c'est trop sucré c'est
euh c'est la frpan non c'est plutôt le
le goût du beurre là j'aime pas le
beurre ah ben non galette alors pourquoi
parce que j'aime bien la franche du pan
la galette qui l'emporte donc de ce
petit sondage micro trottoir on passe au
sport à présent comme chaque année la
compagnie d'arc a en cours organiser un
concours qualificatif pour les prochains
championnats de France en salle mais
aussi l'ultime étape pour les sélections
pour les Mondiaux qui se se dérouleront
à nî des archers de l'équipe de France
étent présents sur le pas de tir Antony
Resche et Patrick Jacques de dixmud pour
les
images au milieu des 380 participants
pour la plupart amateurs certains
archers ressentent plus de tension sur
la corde de leur arc le vice-champion
d'Europe 2011 Sébastien Pen est présent
sur le pas de tir d'élencour pour se
qualifier pour les prochains
championnats du monde en salle rester
concentré dans dans dans sa bulle voilà
faire attention à tout ce qu'on fait
savoir analyser son son tir pour si
jamais il y a une erreur savoir
l'analyser et apporter un peu plus
d'attention dessus par la suite pour
éviter de répéter le la même erreur
nouvel record man de France du tir en
salle en arcapouli Sophie dodémon fait
partie logiquement des favorites pour
obtenir son ticket pour le groupe France
où seul les huit meilleurs archers
seront retenus l'objectif c'est pas de
rentrer dans les h l'objectif c'est de
c'est de faire un résultat sur le
championnat du monde donc si
effectivement j'ai des difficultés à
rentrer dans les h ça sert à rien que
j'aille plus loin donc euh voilà là j'ai
fait le tir il fallait le faire et tant
mieux dimanche matin Sophie doémon
réalise un bon score de 584 points sur
600 possible avec ce total elle valide
facilement son ticket pour la sélection
nationale qui aura lieu dans 15 jours et
tire toujours après une médaille d'or au
mondiaux peut-être anime fin
février autre rendez-vous sportif
d'envergure ce weekend les 32e de finale
de la Coupe de France de football poissi
était le dernier club yvelinois issu du
football à ateur encore en LCE les
joueurs de Thierry bet qui évolu en
championnat en CFA 2 recevait concarne
pensionnaire e de CFA l'exploit ne s'est
pas produit au stade Léo laagrange le
résumé d'Antony
Resche si le match des tribunes est vite
gagné par les supporters de concarne
c'est tout l'opposé sur le terrain du
stade léoagrange après un début de match
très prudent les joueurs de poissie ici
en jaune asphixie le milieu breton et
ils sont même tout prêts d'ouvrir le
score sur cette splendide ouverture mais
la reprise de l'attaquant pisiqueet
passe tout près de la lucarne bretonne
voici prend alors confiance et les
occasions se multiplient mais à chaque
fois non cadré même quand la cage
adverse est vide
0-0 à la pause le tournant du match
arrive peu après la mi-temps le
défenseur central abdouah Sangare est
expulsé pour ce tacle en
retard il n'en fallait pas plus au
joueurs de Concarneau pour prendre
l'avantage à la 70e minute l'avant
centre breton soki enzinga mais fin aux
espoirs evvinois sur cette frappe
croisée du gauche conc Carno s'impose
finalement 1 à0 et verra les 16e de
finale 24 ans après de leur côté les
ivelinois pourront regretter longtemps
leurs nombreuses occasions ratées on
avait pas fait un grand début de match
peut-être impressionné par l'événement
mais mais tout de suite derrière on a on
a comment on s'est bien ressaisi on a
bien joué on a on a les occases et on
les met pas
et et puis après l'expulsion t du match
en seconde période exclusion très sévère
on jouit pour la Calif on a perdu donc
c'est une déception et pour un point
complet sur l'actualité sportif
rendez-vous chaque lundi soir 18h30
19h30 et 22h30 sur TVfil avec le 78
sport préparé par Anthony res en ce
début du mois de janvier nous revenons
sur les moments forts de l'année écoulée
c'est une tradition après le premier
semestre la semaine dernière voici un
résumé et des événements forts de
juillet à septembre une rétrospective
signée Catherine
zulato l'été 2013 est marqué notamment
par deux événements majeurs aux
antipodes l'un de l'autre ce sont tout
d'abord des émeutes à trrape à la
mi-juillet à l'origine un contrôle d'une
femme portant le voile intégral qui
tourne mal son mari est interpellé pour
avoir tenté d'étrangler un policiers des
jeunes reprochent aux policiers des
propos et des attitudes islamophobes et
le passage du Tour de France qui pour
son centenaire est passé à
ans en Yveline non loin du Vélodrome qui
sera officiellement inauguré le 30
janvier prochain ultim entre versaill et
les champs-élysé c'était le 21 juillet
dernier les coureurs sont donc passés
dans les rues de Montini notamment bondé
pour l'occasion avec des fans qui
supportaient des coureurs venus de très
loin ah si si si on on les suit mon père
est super fan depuis que je suis né on
les suit chaque
annéeb un mois de septembre marqué aussi
par la mise en place de la réforme
scolaire dans les ivblines parmi les
villes qui ont fait ce choix celle de
trappe 300000 à 667 ivinois ont fait
leur rentrée et à trappe cela s'est
passé de façon paisible est venu nous
dire la première adjointe Janine Marie
un bilan sera tiré en ce début d'année
2014 les horaires ont été modifiés
retardés de 20 minutes le matin la pause
méridienne est inchangée et il termine à
16h15 l'après-midi ils peuvent rester
jusqu'à 16h30 ce quart d'heure est un
quart d'heure offert aux parents c'est
gratuit et puis après la journée se
continue comme elle se passait
précédemment un temps consacré au bouté
aux leçons et puis les activités qui
vont commencer avec les prestataire de
service lundi prochain toujours à
trrappe 80000 véhicules traversent
chaque jour la National 10 elle sera
bientôt couverte sur une longueur de 400
m environ le projet n'est pas nouveau
mais il manque à les fond pour le
concrétiser et c'estes choses faites un
courrier signé du ministre des
Transports qui confirme une volonté
d'avancer un début du mois de septembre
marqué également par des inaugurations
d'abord à hlencour une nouvelle
résidence pour les étudiants à ouvert
offrant 161 logements à saint-cien
d'école le lycée professionnel
Jean-Perrin a inauguré ses nouveaux
locaux après 8 ans de chantier le
président PS de la Région île-de-fance a
fait le déplacement pour couper le ruban
34 millions d'euros du conseil régional
ont été investis la réhabilitation
permet à l'établissement de consolider
ses formations notamment celle d'optique
lunetterie c'est le seul lycée public du
département à proposer cette filière à
Montini le Bretonneux c'est la fin des
travaux de rénovation de la gare la
Salle des pas perdu est dotée d'une
signalétiique plus claire l'espace a été
décloisonné avec 25000 usagers par jour
et sans rénovation importante depuis
1975 les locaux était devenu plus que
vétuste des travaux à hauteur de 1,8
million d'euros financés en moitié par
la Région Île-de-France et la SNCF les
aménagements extérieurs devraient se
prolonger jusqu'en
2017 et puis ce mois de septembre des
événements également politiques la venue
tout d'abord d'Arnaud Montebourg le
ministre du redressement productif au
siège de cassdian à hencour c'était une
première visite pour le ministre autour
de la Nouvelle-France industrielle en ce
début du mois de septembre arnaau mbourg
a annoncé 34 plans de reconquête
industrielle le but rendre les secteurs
innovants plus concurrentiels deux
marchés ont ici été évoqué la
cybersécurité et le développement du
réseau 4G nous investissons là où nous
pouvons obtenir des créations d'emploi
l'art de la guerre comme disaient tous
les stratèges militaires c'est de
concentrer nos fort sur les points forts
et non pas de les disperser sur nos
points faibles lui aussi est un
personnage très attendu en ce début de
rentrée politique Pierre Bédier première
séance du conseil général en ce 30
septembre et retour en politique pour
celui qui avait occupé le fauteuil de
président de 2005 à 2009 2009 date à
laquelle il avait abandonné son poste
après avoir été condamné à 3 ans de
privation de droits CIVI pour corruption
passive et recelle d'abus de biens
sociaux pendant la séance l'élu MP est
apparu concentré très silencieux et n'a
pas pris part au débat et puis il a
aussi été question d'intercommunalité en
ce mois de septembre au 1er janvier 2014
et les villes doivent s'associer en
intercommunalité mais Cell constituée de
plaisir villepr et les clés sous boois
démarrent bien mal la mare udi des clés
sous-bois Véronique cotémillard a remis
en cause ce mariage à tro jugé inutile
coûteux les deux autres maires font
cause commune et tendent la main à leur
troisième comparse un feuilleton qui ne
fait que débuter à la fin de notre rétro
2013 ce sera demain mardi dès 18h en
direct dans laactu si vous n'étiez pas
avec nous au début de cette édition je
vous remontre à préssent l'image du jour
la visite d'une partie du gouvernement à
Versailles cet après-midi c'est au
château que ministre de l'Emploi
ministre du droit des femmes ministre de
la réforme de l'État et Premier ministre
ont rencontré des représentants de la
société l'aînée de l'eau en charge de
travaux de restauration du pavillon du
four un déplacement sur le thème de la
mixité professionnelle et le droit des
femmes puisque cette entreprise a
développé un programme d'amélioration et
d'aménagement des postes pour les rendre
accessibles et adaptés à ces dernières
Jean-Marc hraud a aussi présenté les
actions qui seront engagé cette année
par le gouvernement la visite qui s'est
terminée en fin de journée résumé
complet les explications ce sera dans
notre édition de demain mardi
rendez-vous donc dès 18h en direct
replay gratuitement sur notre site Inter
internet on se quitte avec vos
résolutions pour la nouvelle année
excellente soirée essayez de tenir pour
la santé voilà et toute la famille voilà
que toute la famille aille bien c'est
important moi c'est me laisser pousser
la barbe arrêter de fumer arrêter de bah
tout ce qui est contre contre la vie de
d'offrir plein de bonheur à tout le
monde trouver la femme de ma vie travail
euh coffrer de l'argent travail trouver
un travail construire une vie trouver
une vie affronter la vie de manière plus
sereine et et euh voilà essayer de
toujours donner du bien autour de soi
voilà arrêtez de
fumer